das ist das fragen lotto die roten sind
unverschämte fragen die grünen sind
harmlose fragen du kannst du viel ziehen
wie du möchtest du kannst sind gucken
beim zielen du kannst weggucken ja wenn
ich jetzt grünen sehen wenig zu fordern
schon ja oder nicht also weiß ich mich
also
sie gewannen die 1live krone als bester
künstler finden sie diese auszeichnung
gerechtfertigt
also gerechtfertigt ist erstmal gar
nichts aber
ich habe mich darüber gefreut und fühle
mich sehr geil weil es war mein erster
mein erster preis überhaupt so und das
nachdem ich das alles schon sehr
lange mache und deshalb
freut es dass ab doch gerechtfertigt
weil ich es einfach mein erster preis
war nach
20.000 platten doch ja kann ich schon
sagen auch wenn ich ein bisschen sehr
bescheiden ist das viel zu sagen
gut also wir sind ja noch mehr schön und
so ok ja lieber
management nur noch eine
zeit ist um das wäre jetzt auch nie da
muss ich noch so eine rote ziehen ich
bin ich gebe es mehr auf hartz
grün kannst du drin lassen für prinz pi
die beginner boba fett als sie als und
jan delay haben sie es nötig sich hinter
so vielen pseudonymen zu verstecken ich
finde ja nicht hat die fragen also da
möchte ich die grünen gar nicht
einschlafen
also das ist
ich hatte es tatsächlich nötig oder das
war eben auch deshalb sind die überhaupt
entstanden die pseudonyme das war der
gedanke dahinter eben nicht weil ich war
selber als fan und konsument immer so
ein bisschen enttäuscht war mich
bekommen vom rap und einen laptop oder
so wenig der befand unter seinem namen
dann auf einmal irgendwie ein bossa nova
album gemacht haben ich bin einen
plattenladen dieses neue von blau und
dann von ems in geilo hallo und dann
kommt ihr auf einmal errungen
und dann ist da ja was soll das denn
jetzt und ich habe mich aber immer schon
für verschiedene musik interessiert und
hat wie dann auch irgendwann zu machen
und dann fingen das halt an als ich dann
la boum ist dass dabei ist nicht dabei
okay aber da hatte ich dann einen namen
weil das war so instrumentale
elektronische mucke dann habe ich es
gemacht habe wollte ich unbedingt einen
anderen namen haben als eisfeld wie ich
zu der zeit hieß und wollte dass man das
auch als reggae musik dann warnend und
weiß wenn der jan delays gut jetzt macht
er etwas anderes aber das zeigt allein
schon dass mir diese pseudonym scheiße
inzwischen scheißegal ist aber damals
war mir deshalb wichtig mich dahinter zu
verstecken und boba fett zb der name der
ist wirklich direkt entworfen wurden
alle haben sich einen zweiten namen
zugelegt hinter dem sie sich verstecken
konnten das war zu der zeit als wir
gerade als es derbe durch die decke
gehen und über eine kamera war wenn man
einfach mal nur retten wollte und wir
wollten halt auch mal wieder anonym
einfach wie früher und haben die steirer
gegründet und jeder die waren alle
bekannt und jeder hat sich einen anderen
namen geben also insofern ist es schon
ein zeichenprogramm multipler
persönlichkeit dass die musik betrifft
genau und auch einen sich dahinter
verstecken definitiv aber nicht aus
feigheit sondern einfach gezielt aus
ja weil man es kontrollieren will
irgendwie mehr was man macht noch ein
grund wie es aufgenommen wird noch eine
rote jetzt nämlich eine grüne mit ok sie
kann ich dann auch schneller beantwortet
wenn sie sage mal so weit
ihre texte sind eloquent und witzig
sollen aber auch zum nachdenken anregen
wie lernen und so einen song writing
das kann ich nicht kurz beantworten
ich kann nur sagen das ist das wie ich
vorhin meinte ich weiß jetzt nicht ob
man das irgendwo dann im anderen
interview nach klicken kann noch einmal
gut dass es einfach darum geht du lernst
immer immer mehr also mein erster song
wenn ich den jetzt entscheide mich in
grund und boden so was alles anbelangt
egal ob musik oder text oder floh oder
sound so dass alles schlimm und ab da
geht es halt immer nur aufwärts und so
kann man das nur lernen indem man immer
weiter am ball bleibt aus jedem fehler
lernt muss immer versucht weiterzumachen
und sich selbst immer am meisten zu
unterhalten und zu entertainen dann kann
man sich irgendwann
findet man sein instrumentarium und weiß
wie man das für sich darüber am besten
löst aber man lernt trotzdem nie aus
gibt immer wieder gut dann wünsche ich
noch ganz viele fehler damit